Dan Orlovsky star is on the rise at the
mothership ESPN football analyst former
NFL quarterback and you can check him
out on get up with my Greenberg Sports
Center NFL live and other programs best
uniform you played in was what din well
played him
definitely the creamsicle Tampa Bay
Buccaneers we got to wear them once and
these were like the old school material
too so they're the comfort of them was
atrocious
but the feel of like the look of them
was awesome now this is when we stuck so
we probably got dragged by whoever we
plays but the best one I played in is
the Tampa Bay Buccaneer creamsicle or
the Lions Thanksgiving Day throw backs
when it's just all blue jersey false
gray numbers gray pants on all blue
helmet those were the cleanest that I've
worn myself alright Dan that's all we
wanted from you thank you we appreciate
your time I was just talking about this
that the second most important position
on the field is an edge rusher in my
opinion so you had the quarterback and
you have the edge rusher I don't know if
you agree or not but I'll let you give
me your opinion on that in a moment why
is it nobody wants to trade up to get
chase young if he is is a generational
you know once in a decade kind of pass
rusher in the best player in the draft I
haven't heard one trade scenario to go
up and get him money yeah I'd say number
one there are some people and I thought
conversations with guys about this that
do believe he went ghost the last three
games of the year that he was minimized
and shut down and especially in the
Clemson game people point to that I
disagree with that point I actually
thought the teams that played them down
the stretch were conscious of him and
getting the ball out of their hands Wade
quicker than normal I think there's the
reality that I don't think there's any
chance Washington trades to pick I just
don't I mean Ron Rivera and Jack Del Rio
they're washington's defensive line has
going to be a major problem because just
as a quarterback makes everybody better
a dominant defensive lineman makes all
those other defensive linemen better and
so now Montes sweat is going to be
better and pains going to be better and
Jonathan Allen is going to be better
because of the addition to chase down so
I don't think Washington would be
willing to move from that pic I would
disagree with you on the edge rusher
being more important than the interior
rusher two reasons one the the usage of
the field the spread of the field
coaches are much more aware that the
football field is actually fifty three
and a third yards wide and much more
willing to use all of that space and so
now I always try to express it like this
I think of an offensive line and
traditionally over the last thirty years
of the NFL you know the offensive line
is tackled to tackle for the most part
and that's probably a six or seven yard
wide space and once the ball has
traditionally been snapped because we
weren't using space as much the field
wide with the offensive line is like an
accordion that gets shrunk and so those
pass rushers get closer and closer to
the quarterback that are taking these
five and seven set drops and sitting in
the pocket when now coaches expand the
offensive line more at the ball being
snapped whether it's the use of lateral
play-action which is much more part of
the NFL now than then it used to be the
quick passing game in the screen game
the the lateral run game is much more
used than the downhill run game and then
the second thing it would be is how
quickly the ball gets out of
quarterbacks hands I mean we see the
ball get out of quarterbacks hands with
the RPO game way faster than it used to
be you know one last time you saw a
quarterback under center and take a
seven step drop just traditional drop
back not a play-action game it's just
it's not part of the game as much
anymore and so the interior pass rusher
as close to the quarterback that's
possible person is more valuable for me
and in my experience and then the edge
rusher yeah I get that because that's
why Aaron Donald is so valuable he's
disruptive in the middle plus to get to
the quarterback he can get there quicker
than the edge rusher can and if you're
taking less than you know two and a half
seconds get rid of the football
you know let's the the you know closest
distance between you know two dots here
go straight right at me so I I
understand that if you look at these
drafts and and I've said this it seems
like every year I say the same thing we
build up a quarterback and then we tear
him down as we get closer to the draft
so it's a rollercoaster ride for these
guys hey this guy's unbelievable in
March then all
sudden April you know the guy's not a
top-10 pick so we didn't do it with
borough we did it and we still doing it
with to uh Herbert Lee he's sort of on
the rise now Jordan love got some
attention there but how do you sort of
sort this all out and understand what
teams are thinking about these players
yeah I don't really believe in ranking
the quarterbacks like one through three
four five six I look at them like okay
what guys are in the best position trait
wise or skillset wise to be bona fide
stars like to be guys that you can just
count on for the next fifteen years to
be rock stars no matter really who their
coaches or who they're who's around them
skill so like these guys are going to be
great players and it's burrow in engine
to uh those are the two players
quarterback wise in this trap like Joe
burrow if you looked at the grace in the
NFL over the last twenty or it's a
deposition and you and you just kind of
took away the first thing that pops in
your head when you think about that
player Joe burrow has it like okay Tom
Brady Oh poised for clutch this when Joe
Broz got that Drew Brees accuracy when
Joe girl has that Ben Roethlisberger
pocket movement Joe Broz ridiculous at
it if you look at Russell Wilson his
instincts Roberto has all that stuff
these are things that like so many
people overlook because they're really
difficult to measure unless you've you
don't really trained your eyes that's it
Joe Broz got all of that like all of it
onto uh it is very similar in that
regard like to an accuracy is the
greatest attribute that he has it's also
the most important attribute physically
a quarterback that kid has and so his
ability to get through progressions I
call it the most programmed quarterback
in the draft not robotic but programs so
those two guys are rock stars they're
going to be studs
if healthy for two obviously on Herbert
to me it is like my analogies been like
you know when you go house shopping and
you see this house it's a beautiful home
and it's got all the upgrades and it
should sell really well but it just sits
on the market because every time you see
the house you a man something's wrong
with that just doesn't feel right and
and I've kind of sent this tweet out the
other day
think of all the quarterbacks that we've
talked about in the draft in the last
15-20 years that when the first two or
three things out of people's mouths are
he's big he's strong he's athletic he's
got a powerful arm like think of all
those guys in all more that more often
than not those cats have failed and I
didn't say anything about that when it
came to brady russell wilson Brees Big
Ben I didn't say anything about that
because that stuff doesn't matter we
looked at quarterbacks the same way we
look at all the other positions big
strong athletic powerful it should be
the other way the mental and so that's
what concerns me about Justin Herbert is
like no one's going man it's got great
instincts or gosh is accuracies
ridiculous or he's just got this ability
to make all these different kinds of
those those are all the things that
people talk about her like that I talk
about that he struggles with and I just
go man I I would have a lot of concern
about that because it's the most
important physical attributes of the
quarterback position and then for Jordan
loved you know Jordan love is the the
most intriguing probably God because he
does more stuff that you can't coach
more Wow stuff people man I just can't
coach that throw I can't coach that
throw I kind of related to this Patrick
the Holmes who has he he has been
compared to I don't see that but I'm
Patrick the Holmes has this recess style
of football where like he's the best kid
on the playground and it's under control
and he's just toying with people and
Jordan luff has a reckless style of
football where it looks somewhat similar
but goodness it's reckless and so listen
if you can coach him up to be more
recessed and reckless then yeah you you
might have something to work with but
I'm not taking them until later in the
first wrong I I'm gonna go with your
analogy here with Justin Herbert there's
a house and there's a home he might be a
house as a quarterback where jobber or
two it could be a home in there there's
a big difference in that it looks great
but it is is it going to be a home if
the team if you pass on to it to take
Justin Herbert finish that sentence
you're scared to be great you're here
okay with trying to be mediocre
but it's at the figure of taking him or
the fear of not taking him which one do
you think is stronger in this store
with to it I the fear of taking him and
I said that I said that in January it's
going to take courage to take to it
let's be honest it's going to take
courage to pass on to it
because this is the same guy that in
kirkuk she's great right Kirk's treatise
is is outstanding at what he does and I
think he's got a great feel and
understanding of that spot that position
cause football it's the same person the
same player that came into the national
championship game and Kurt Herbstreit
on the broadcast said Alabama's gonna be
okay
this kid is ridiculous it's the same
coach and Nick Saban who we all saves
they're one of the greatest coaches of
all time who decided to go to that
player in that moment and so if it's if
a team decides to dress
Justin Herbert's it's just they are so
scared that Toa is going to become hurt
that they're they're willing to become
to chase mediocrity than greatness
they'd rather play it safe and it's
funny I was just watching her stake and
Michael Jordan was talking about the
last dance thing and he was talking
about in his first year he had an injury
and the doctors told them there's a
there's a 90% chance you won't get her
and there's a 10% chance that you'll get
hurt and you'll end your career and
Jordan looked at him like but I'm like
I'm trying to be great there's a 90%
chance there's a 90% chance that if you
dress to a ton of I Aloha you're gonna
become great as an organization he's
that's thinking good but if you want to
bet on the 10% because you're scared
then that's on you then later that year
in the playoffs and Jordan puts 63 on
the Celtics in the garden yeah I guess I
get like listen and I brought this up
okay so look at the past like 10 years
in the NFL
okay thanks like you don't get great in
the NFL without taking risk this st.
when onside kick in the Superbowl 10 11
years ago and the Super Bowl at halftime
the Eagles a couple years ago as the
number one so you decided to go into the
the playoffs with a backup quarterback
and and ran a trick play on fourth and
goal that the Chiefs traded up to get a
quarterback from Texas Tech when they
didn't need to they had a veteran or a
playoff football team the Ravens took a
quarterback in the marg X and that
couldn't fit into the NFL like you if
you want to become a great
championship-caliber organization and
you want to become great you've gotta
take risks like you've got to take risks
and I just look at you and go the
quarterbacks are getting way more
protected in the NFL than they are in
college football Wayne were protected
and I think he has the brain to mature
enough to realize I don't have to prove
my toughness every single play get the
ball out and there's other places to
play it I would take good stuff it's
great to talk to you I'm happy for your
success you've done well and you put in
the work and you know maybe in a couple
of months you come here to the man cave
and we'll teach you how to throw a
football and absolute honor I actually
grew up on you so it's a privilege I'm
glad to be with you finally I would love
to come to the man cave I can use all
the help I can get thank you Dan we
appreciate your time till greeny we
settle oh I won't be well that's Dan
Orlovsky